I'll forego impressed my name is Pierre
in the back how nice of you to stop by
we're playing some wolf among us let's
continue here so you bros decided I read
the comments and and you said I will go
with froggy fro so that's what we're
gonna do and we ended up going out the
window and I landed on toads car
you guys made a real mess holy Sh it's
still there in the day oh damn
somebody up there
that is not toad why should we yell at
him seriously wait here
see see I mean that was not the wrong
decision that was a right decision
because I didn't yell now he can sneak
up on it
well [ __ ] maybe not he's gonna get
sucker punch no what's with the funky
music maybe I gotta change my [ __ ] there
you go
hey see it didn't matter
you brought the reading to things too
much you said oh you should have given
the girl money
well they mean maybe then she would have
lived she dies any [ __ ] way yeah I
still like you okay a girl is crying
Peter pie is dying let's go check on her
where is this
maybe I said crap is it in the air SCOR
knows that his son Toad's I think oh
[ __ ]
it sounds like a woman be nice and there
okay why would I not be nice baby and
miss white surely you didn't come all
this way just for my ball huh
maybe we did it's the going on here told
you so ray big feet it's embarrassing to
have to admit but I I thought there was
someone else in we place there wasn't no
not when I checked nothing but a leaky
drainpipe imagination must have got the
best of me so you know [ __ ] I saw
someone was someone but they took off
when we got here is that right I guess
your dad's ears every year or two left
having gone totally to the dogs I
he hates flowers is that it are you
alright
he's fine miss white just stung his
little towel one better swimmer than
Walker and just like his dad
wanna so I guess you'll be taking off
now no need to hang around here anymore
I mean I'm sorry you came all the way if
enough it somebody was in your building
this is for your own safety toad you
called us remember yeah i'll now when I
appreciate you make bets fine
relax I'll be out of here in a minute I
just want to check things out first all
right all right I just don't want to
waste your time is oh but it's going
I'll have a seat I have a cup of tea
whatever you like poof grown-ups am i
right oh you know what flycatcher said
you had a pretty awesome insect
collection I'd really love to see it is
it in your room so tiny I just want to
kick him it has a weevil cool well look
at snows legs
just mind the upholstery while you're
looking for nothing yeah sure thing
about this what happened here huh
now this happened [ __ ] it no damn thing
must have fell off the table uh-huh the
lamp just fell off the table well the
boy was puffing about play insult since
old Fisher knows with the light
why is there something there oh it
wasn't plugged in I know what that was
you're not telling me something mr. toad
that doesn't matter
I'm gonna let the evidence speak for
itself what's this blood doing here
you're bleeding y-yes that's blood still
fresh Wow well I'll cut me and run
around like a tick trying to pick out a
wrap
mustard got someone punishments mind if
I sign the pieces blood on the wall it's
awful Oh sounds painful
why don't you go mavar ening now they
won't didn't sit very long you know
possibly a fable I suppose and a frog
what's going on oh I Clos must use my
wolf senses smile if it's blood you know
what I've been dot there's marks here on
the window sill and what's Adam yeah no
real reason just last night will not
come out I was in a down Rock dizzy mate
as you would be done forgot the keys to
this place
and I had to climb in through the bloody
window real yes that's so her junior off
to death he's lying you're a filthy liar
we regret picking him now cuz huh damn
someone got that up his ass what
happened here the Polka whoa
there's more blood on the tip and this
happened before or after you came in the
window after after I was I was poking
the coals and it slipped a bit sliced up
in my foot like a seashell but like a
[ __ ] ugly thing if you're gonna say
something out live it
I thought you cut your hand Wade you
dropped it on your foot you told me
before that you cut your hand yeah no I
did cut my a I'll cut my hand first and
that made me drop the damn thing on my
foot ruinous flip of events really
come on this buses is already oh my god
will you not make a big fat out of this
there's nothing to solve a sheriff I'm
telling you everything that happened
she's like me someone swung that way I
mean things happen you know I think
someone was attacking a goddamn a mesh
tote it looks like after a struggle or a
fight I know you're lying about so I
know you're just gonna make it worse for
yourself the longer you keep up the act
I'm not bullshitting you honest well hey
I know a bullfrog when I see a
bullshitter
and I [ __ ] my ass when you both see
it all of them are there right no that
was [ __ ] now I'm the bullshitter
let's look around a little bit more we
never really used them the items that
much but you know
you know you know you love fantastic
person oh he likes Monaco huh it's how I
shine with a little [ __ ]
never been good with the feminine jury's
own body stuff with my clumsy hands
I know something's off here toad and I
know you know I can't leave until I find
out why so can we please just skip to
the end of the page before I have to get
mean I don't know what you won't Big B
there's nothing going on
or should we do it's the grand more
all right let's talk to snow
so most people think they are uh-huh
very interesting how's it going
no tidings something that I don't know
what yet kids say anything no nothing
really
he was really upset though earlier he
won't say why something's going on
stay with the kid until I figure out
what okay so we're not leaving until we
know for sure but I wanted to check
upstairs as well there's a busted latch
here and see that why is the lock busted
yeah there we go
looks like somebody kicked in the door
and this doesn't have anything to do
with the blood for Christ's sakes it
[ __ ] looks been busted for weeks mate
right it's just like everything else in
this bloody building [ __ ] bloody hell
Big B what sinister bit of you uncut
there we go
I lit the tap water running didn't shut
the recycling what's the point of all
this mate really why did you climb in
through the window yeah huh why'd you
climb in through the window you said it
yourself the locks been rotten for weeks
you wouldn't have needed a key to get in
okay now just what are you on about
right
I'm to the state I was in or didn't have
me head that's all it was
I forgot a [ __ ] handle was [ __ ]
back don't you [ __ ] fire you or else
it's embarrassing you're bringing all
this [ __ ] up all right so quit it with a
third degree how about you quit [ __ ]
liar you piece of [ __ ]
okay now I'm tired now it's time to
intimidate now it sounds a little bleak
but I will take over unless I didn't
find all the colors what do you guys
think
I feel like there's nothing we really
missed and there's nothing really more
to investigate so I think it's time to
intimidate there's something okay a ring
move something won't you mate there's a
clean space and the dust over here maybe
one of juniors toys or something I mean
another lying piece of poop is suppose
there's another lie do we know what you
want
that's the third lie mr. I'm sick I hear
when you're [ __ ]
am i easier has all out what that's
disgusting
the broken laugh was he a [ __ ] broken
lamp used to be here right just tell me
what happened nothing that bit mate
nothing and why did the lab have to be
there of all the bloomin pointless
inquiries it's my own place the power
happens in it because it wasn't on that
table toad there isn't any room in the
electric outlets huh walking is plugged
in over here and now it's there yeah
some free think of it [ __ ] go it did
not plug it in come on toad I'll just
died and gotten around to it yet you see
how many damp like said why don't I want
to see your ass begging for mercy over
ere old boy I was looking forward to a
nice afternoon just me and me son and
you've taken up enough of a day with all
this they're sniffing around it with
private belongings I'm sorry I called
really I am but will you please please
just bugger off your other ones kind of
a bugger off no yeah but after Jenna
[ __ ] anyone Big B there wasn't any strap
so wet when are you gonna leave I mean I
feel like I'm on trial here in the young
bloody yo it's not same lady tell the
truth when you start telling me the
truth
toad well
truth might Jesus cost what more do you
want
you lied told these stories have made no
sense you didn't cut yourself on the
Pope did it we did it we played it
correctly you didn't forget your keys
yeah you didn't bump the lamp off the
table you want to tell me what's going
on
she doesn't think much of me I don't
think oh I wouldn't necessarily say
hello is t-shirt progress yes death for
this lie you're bleeding
if it it about time you got you
it was that butcher a a tweedle dumber d
you got to strip him down to the
Johnnies before you can tell which is
which
they come bulging in screaming about
something a woodsman aid for [ __ ] aid
I don't know
he told up that place pick me up when I
said I didn't have it I tried to go out
the window
but he pulled me back in he's been an
old moaning I could tell you that was he
looking for is he looking for I have no
idea I would have told you
I wanted to really know why the [ __ ] did
you lie say they would have this ever
got back to him if he ever thought you
knew or miss wife they'd come back and
kill my poor don't say that in front of
your son you stupid [ __ ] to get the
bastard a coat you wouldn't take it
whose coat the girl dad borrows things
from people who live here sometimes
still nothing turn around here would
astonish you mate no merely repossess
what's been left behind
well we'll be taking the coat now if she
has next of kin family anyone all right
touch him the fur fine bit of dress at
ease slob they put it there
what the [ __ ]
wait there is a note there it's an
envelope you know series for my luck
it's a map to some bloody doubloons
it's addressed to prince long do you
want to try and give it to him er it
belongs to Lawrence we're going to
Lawrence anyway right opening another
man's mail yeah let's try and give it
yeah we're going to him anyway well it's
been quite a surprise nitros fishes I'd
see you out but I'm afraid to dripping
any more blood in the place it was very
nice talking to you TJ he's soft TJ
hombre see ya see a nugget
interesting character
see right decisions all of them don't
you dare go that smoothly no not
understood genius so the princess now
Lawrence's yeah it's our best kale yeah
we're going to Lauren's now cool I
wonder what changes depending on who you
pick first I don't want to stay here any
longer than we have to so let's just
pick an approach and stick to it okay
just humor me
and the magic mirrors showed me this
apartment I think I saw a knife inside
covered in what looked like Bluff day
yeah wasn't expecting her well like I
said let's not important placate things
you can question him while I look around
for it and if you objects-- we are here
on official Fabletown business and we
can be persuasive if necessary or you
can yay good with the Lauren's house
girl coming to Lauren's house girl come
to lowering up going to load up got a
large hot girl mailed it that's just my
wait
and he's dead what was it I said why
don't you come over to my bed just
kidding girl you can't do that
cuz I Drock too important to cancer it
just rhymes it strikes again huh geez
thanks again genius strikes again Junior
your socks again
what's up Lawrence that's how much these
days huh oh my god oh she's not that ho
[ __ ] hi-yah stay with me hey hey stay
with me Lawrence I kind of find the clue
out of him before he dies she uh-huh
what is it that you're telling us
Big B water kitchen what do I have to go
oh [ __ ] sorry okay the water how do you
transport it with the glass yes of
course
wine I think he looks a badass I kind of
had those teeth too Edgar
no I'm recording if you have something
to ask him you should do it yes let's
get a final clue item in who did this to
you who did this to you Hey really
no no no no no he's just saying it
because he loves her and anything
oh [ __ ] pee do you still have that
letter yeah I guess we can open it now
should I open it yes I'm not sure if
it's right it is Ryan he died come on
there might be something that helps yeah
a clue or lead yeah come on I need to
know it's important we don't have any
other say I'm sorry
think geez it's only two words but he
died without seeing them I'm sorry too
maybe he'll come back guesses ambi we
need to figure out what happened here
and find whoever did this
but how all right press gonna have to
end episode here hope you enjoyed
watching maybe like if you did I really
appreciate all the support stay awesome
bros live you alright here we go